faut faire ce qu'on aime est ce qu'on a
envie il fallait attendre dit m après
pourquoi ces rencontres et ces ya vingt
ans pour la sortie de votre premier
album 10000 matin quelle est la
différence entre le dernier lelouch et
d'aujourd'hui et daniel boucher diomède
parce que vous n'êtes pas mal supporté
la protection web avec quelle période
ma première manche j'étais dans la fin
de la vingtaine ok j'étais célibataire
j'écrivais des tonnes j'avais un premier
disque qui avaient du succès j'avais
évidemment pas de famille pas d'enfants
pas de maison pas de charge j'avais
aucune responsabilité
tout ce que j'avais à faire quand je me
levais c'était d'être un chanteur rock
je n'oublierai jamais cette période là
de ma vie j'ai tellement tripé et j'ai
encore là je me trouve chanceux d'avoir
vix s'est pas l'échelle mondiale mais
j'ai quand même vécu quelque chose de
vraiment spécial au tournant des années
de neil moitié j'ai tellement eu une
faune dans cette période normale je suis
content aussi que ce soit derrière moi
parce qu'elle est belle ma vie a changé
au sillage une maison en haut d'une
montagne j'ai trois enfants était jeune
femme merveilleuse
josé je suis beaucoup plus heureux
aujourd'hui qu'à cette époque lors la
bad m mais quand je pense à cette
période le écoute c'est ce gars là bas
n'en sorte a été résistible c'est ce que
vous avez vraiment le montréalais
vous êtes en gaspésie présentement oui
oui pourquoi vous avez fait ce choix-là
de vous réinventer à quelque part parce
que vous n'êtes plus le même
chansonniers du tout le tu content que
tu dises parce que le contrat à voudrait
dire que je me répète
j'apprends à force est de moins en moins
et ça ça fait énormément de bien
j'apprends en force est de moins en
moins quand je parle quand je chante
quand je joue de la guitare quand
j'enregistre et quand je réussis à
ouvrir le canal pour capter des
nouvelles tonnes j'apprends force est de
moins en moins
et souvent quand je force - j'ai non
seulement des résultats qui me font
autant plaisir mais plus au site
parce que tout coule de source et
naturel pourquoi vous repartez sur la
route avec vos plus grands succès et une
tournée en 2020 cette grosse année pour
vous oui
premièrement j'ai jamais arrêté en tant
que tel tuer
je suis moins visible médiatiquement
joly c'est bon et c'est aussi en partie
un choix parce que je m'ennuie pas
nécessairement de l'exposition
médiatique que je vais dans ce temps-là
je sais que c'est nécessaire pour faire
connaître le projet c'est nécessaire
pour qu'on te voit pour qu'on
éventuellement achète écoute ta musique
l'achète mon choix mais c'est un moyen
c'est pas une fin il ya eu une période
au début de ma carrière j'ai tel hymne
être surexposé ben moi je trouvais que
des fois moi j'aime ça parler de musique
j'aime / alléchante et j'aime ça allait
parler de musique quand ça déborde ça je
traite moins mais la compétition est pas
mal plus forte parce que quand vous avez
commencé il y avait les paul piché
michel rivard jean leloup daniel
bélanger tout dépend des champions des
géants
moi je les écoute segel hockey
charlebois l'eiu bon rivard et compagnie
fred fortin ces dégâts qu'ils disent ce
qu'ils pensent et aujourd'hui où il a de
plus en plus nombreux oui c'est
complètement transformé l'industrie
c'est qu'au lieu je te dirai
créativement peut-être surprendre mais
oui au niveau de la créativité le fait
que le fait que ce soit devenu difficile
de vendre des disques donc de tirer des
revenus de la musique ça ça va 100 ça a
donné ce sacré dd ça donnait des
créateurs qui font des musiques pour les
bonnes raisons
c'est à dire qu'ils font de la musique
qu'ils aiment la musique qui ont envie
d'écouter eux mêmes je te dis pas que
paul piché faisait pas de la musique à
son goût mais il y avait une espèce
d'âge d'or de l'industrie qui était très
structuré qui fonctionnait très bien
ok mais qui donnait souvent
je veux pas dire d'efforts mais il faut
faire attention à ce qu'on dit parce que
moi j'écoute la musique de cette époque
le jeune hleb le sais mais je constate
aujourd'hui qu'il ya de plus en plus
d'artistes et de plus en plus d'artistes
vraiment créatif qui font vraiment de la
musique à leur goût ce que j'ai moins
remarqué mon à cette époque exercice ne
suis pas vraiment
je regarde le lac
il est calme il est bien
il me mène à penser aux cadeaux qui s'en
vient
[Musique]